[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quoi
c'est
[Musique]
à
et paris
[Musique]
c'est beau
ben ali
kimo
[Musique]
m
on
alors jean comment ça va ça va ça va
bien très bien très bien
l'outil sacerdoce pour faire boire les
verts combien de générations depuis 40
qui a eu 40 années peu près mais combien
de générations vous qu'est ce qui vous
pousse à continuer à passer connu ici
parce que je suis bien je suis bien je
m'amuse le premier supprimiez clients de
la maison est le plus ancien en plus de
champagne s'il vous plaît dimanche on
n'entend pas du tout leur soutien
j'adore ce sont donc elles soient
fatigués ou pas
alors raconte un peu que tu fais quoi
j'ai écrit dans mon message et 400 pages
250 450 kg c'est que le premier tome de
combien j'en ai écrit douce en la sape l
histoire de france rires et ses hommes
ouais merci l'histoire de france
saintonge deuxième tome s'appellera les
derniers jours tu sais c'est très
déconcertant c'est ce que tu écris 458
public à 150 pages après avoir travaillé
quatre ans oui tu essaies de faire que
ce soit un peu près en france je sais
d'avoir un peu d'invention d'imagination
du tu vis avec ton affaire fecris ton
livre tu te montre pas beaucoup du
travail et tu publies ton livre et
personne ne lit et tout le monde tant
mais en disant à gnagna est-ce que c'est
mitterrand n'ya ni à ce que ces duchmol
c'est très décourageant
on écrit pour 300 personnes 400 les gens
ne te parles de ton livre te disent bien
sûr je n'ai pas vu donc maintenant ils
ont même pu l'avant et ses chevaliers ou
jeu gelé sur ma table de chevet et
maintenant ils disent qu'ils sont je le
lirai pas que je lirai cet été où j'ai
pas bien il ya un critique qui
s'appelait andré baisse était le gendre
de chardonne où il y avait une très
jolie formule disait une main serré si
un livre lui aujourd'hui on ne serre pas
la main dont ils peuvent plus en plus
dense et très c'est un métier très
désolant c'est un métier absolument
délicieux et ce qui m'exaspère c'est que
c'est plein de gens qui n'ont rien à y
faire
voilà l'édition est encombrée par des
hommes politiques
dès qu'un type est tiré de son ministère
de les publier librement deux ans ilaria
bon dès que quelqu'un
à un an quelque part d'arrêter la
télévision était stérile publie un livre
c'est pas son métier non plus et alors
ça doit pas être quelque chose
d'exclusif il est interdit à personne
c'est permis à tout le monde mais ce qui
est exaspérant ce devoir la
prolifération du papier imprimé
ouais c'est au dieu parce que moi je
vais faire de la politique
est-ce que ça a toujours été aussi
encombre oui oui oui mais on a toujours
écrit pour très peu de monde
les très grands écrivains avaient très
très peu de lecteurs andré gide dû
vendre au maximum un jour un livre
humainement plaire ouais c'était
considéré comme un très grand écrivain
de son époque depuis il a fait beau il a
vendu beaucoup mais en poche
oui donc ç'a toujours été très encombré
mais il y avait autrefois une générosité
on accordait à ce que tu écrivais une
intention de l'iset et on disait c'est
bien ou c'est mauvais aujourd'hui tu
publie un roman au lieu de te dire c'est
bien écrit c'est mal écrit
les personnages sont bons les
personnages sont mauvais l'intrigué
bonne intrigue est mauvaise on te dire
absolument pas ça absolument pas on te
parle de toi donc tu es obligé d'aller
raconter ce que tu fais oui ou bien
entraînement ton avis sur le contenu on
a des chaussures la baisse du dollar est
rempli et un écrivain n'a pas d'avis sur
le le dollar et de la guerre en bosnie
pas plus qu'un joueur de football table
est ce que les chanteurs patrick non
c'est la confusion des genres et les
motards l'édition est encombré par la
confusion des genres temps libre alors
si tu devais me le vendre qui est un
coin qu'il vous jugez pas les prix je te
dis d'aller dans une librairie voilà un
livre qui m'exaspère un peu voilà je
suis un peu énervé tienne fils jean jean
c'est bien de redonner un petit coup de
vis à vis de l'alcool dedans et de la
glace je l'espère
i love paris oui je t'aime
mon voeu parle de beau jeu
j'aime tes bobos
et la sphère qui sommeille bobin
les harakis m toute la semaine
[Musique]
jean dujardin
et
[Musique]
ah pardon merci
classé x excellent sexe classé x
l'index classés x l intox classe élite
parce qu'elle est ici
lascive
[Musique]
c'est
l'amour avec x ou y haut-koenigsbourg
movex classé x
ex classe et expose ses photos à billets
ouais c'est rare bah je sais pas voilà
bien qu'habitué c'est pour les vicieux
où ça allait plutôt toi bien un vrai
attachement pervers et regarder des
photos à bin ouais tu vas là et de
l'aller ça y est balance toi parterre
second fait d'allonger qu'après ça fait
j'y fais là j'ai fêté mon anniversaire
j'ai bien fait de me tailler la route a
fait tester hier soir ouais t'as fait
quoi
j'ai fait une petite fête bonne chance
comme ses sympathies 5,3 pas et tu avais
beaucoup de champagne
non pas trop on doit tout simplement un
geste m tu vois que tu affectionnes 12h
et accompagne et eu à rentrer avec le
même mec que celui avec qui a
aujourd'hui c'est son petit ami s'en va
ça me rassure t inquiètes que tu es de
finale c'est une très belle
ça veut dire qu'il ya encore en ailleurs
par la croûte ouais vous rêvez pas
encore 6 4 et s'est bien passé
t'as pas l'air [__] des téoz est ce
que tu veux boire un tout petit peu de
champagne
c'est un bon anniversaire dis moi c'est
vrai que tu arrêtes de faire du film un
tournant oui j'ai arrêté pourquoi j'ai
arrêté il ya un an et demi ouais parce
que les tous les films pornos sont
tournés sans protection donc j'ai envie
de prendre des risques depuis longtemps
donc j'ai décidé d'arrêter
oui ça fait un petit arabe ainsi devenu
un métier concrètement un risque ouais
donc comme gic 22 ans d'animer arrêté
avant que kiki un drame mais quand tu
leur demandait de mettre des capable
d'arrêter de boire le nom est scandé par
les acteurs les producteurs les deux
parce que un lecteur pense que si met un
préservatif il n'assurera pas donc il a
perdu peur de perdre du boulot donc il
veut pas et les producteurs pensent que
le film aille préservatif c'est pas
intéressant donc ça se vend pas t'as
fait ça de calage à calage des 18 h à 20
de 18h et ses 18 ans la tempête a
commencé comment j'ai commencé magie
comme si j'étais à la fois que la
faculté italien de paris ensuite j'ai
commencé à faire des photos
stigmate barnes comme ça ensuite photos
de charme
j'ai rencontré un agent qui faisait des
films x et donc il m'a proposé d'en
faire j'ai pas voulu tout de suite et
après j'ai accepté d'accéder éducation à
cause duquel ça ne va pas je galère non
pas du tout on en attend la première
fois j'étais très à l'aise ah ouais
ouais enfin bon pour ça non je n'agis
pas agiter pas j'ai pas peur je n'ai pas
peur de montrer une caméra ça me
dérangeait pas il était dépendant de
cachets il était à sa chute à dire on va
papa
oui par rapport à ce que gagne une
actrice en moyenne j'ai appris ça fait
combien de films toujours les films
centaine seront répartis entre
l'allemagne les états unis l'italie et
la france gagner plein d'argent
ouais ça l'a été par an et savent que
taper ça ouais mais sont pas très
content évidemment mais
fils et fille et puis peuvent pas
décider pour mener son comptant de
paraître quand même ah oui c'est très
méchant en allaitant jamais rien de
taper julien sait pas mais non il me
rien dit sur qui veut rien dire abbas a
fait notre façon c'est pas puis c'est
pas grave puis moi j'aime bien chez
nancy chalon c'est pour ça que je
m'appelle et ton petit ami à l'époque
donc où tu faisais ses films lui vivait
ça comment ils y trouvaient simplement
au début pas très bien que moi c'est
normal
puis après je lui ai expliqué je les
fais venir sur des tournages pour qu'ils
sachent et qui je travaillais exactement
ce que je faisais et puis bon bah il est
connu mais vraie motivation donc
l'accepter c'est un boulot stable enfin
pour moi c'est un boulot quand j ai pas
j'ai commencé en disant je vais faire ça
c'est ça ça je le fis pas eh oui et je
vais te payer temps et puis j'y vois lui
il a compris qu'il faisait ça pour
gagner un boulot mais on quitte à pas
laisser faire ça simplement pour arrêter
de travailler par la non du tout
puisqu'il est styliste donc avant tu
regardes d'avoir fait ça n'ont pas dit
où nancy neige dans getafe ne tue point
est hanté par e
rarement franchement bon quart d'heure
ils sont quand même bien non ils sont
pas espérer qu'ils sont bien montés
qu'ils savent souvent ils savent pas
vraiment y faire quoi bon ça va rassurer
beaucoup de gens pensent que non mais
c'est vrai j'ai pas mal j'ai pris mon
pied tout en quoi peut-être quelques
fois deux fois voire tuer mise beaucoup
plus en privé quoi moi vous avez quand
même à faire des trucs avec tanger le
soit en relation m'a pas mal non au
début oui parce que j'étais tellement
crevant quand je rentrais chez moi que
je fatigue est un charmant mais après
non ça va après fur et à mesure comme
j'ai arrêter progressivement quoi donc
je faisais moins en moins de films donc
prés salés j'ai repris un équilibre
normal
ouais tu arrives at amusé avec les
jusqu'à 27
est ce que tu as appris des choses à
apprendre beaucoup de choix ouais ouais
maintenant tu veux être imbattable 1re
étape chez pas mais je me dis que tu
connais je me débrouille c'est vrai tu
adorable merci
[Musique]
les chiens
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
damas nie
ap rhône à eau
c'est pas mal et après on arrive là bas
alors la maison on arrive ça t'es quoi
l'autre on arrive à temps c'est tout les
larmes essuyées à paris pouvait tomber
une pluie alors la scène
oui la scène alors démordre et et paris
se noierait oui mais moi je me dis quand
je bois dans tes yeux quelques là c'est
paris qui peut-être a choisi ces yeux là
pour y accéder la de là
voici les sourires qui sont nés à paris
à six
tous les souris faisant voler
paris et l'onu
c'est
sous la chaleur de ce sont les et dans
l'amour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
trop contente
mais ça se passe sans arrêt mais ils
sont bien mes rêves je garde mon petit
mot non brièvement ce qui se passe je
vous le dis tout de suite là pour pas
parce qu'après ça être trop tard toute
façon non s'il vous plaît bon on en
rigolait maintenant voilà je préfère
vous dire tout de suite il n'y a pas de
fin y'a pas dessus j'ai pas j'en ai pas
fait un bond en jupon l'arc ont dû tous
mpt
hier ils sont restés 5 heures ce que je
l'avais pas dit aux gens mais ils sont
pas faire le dire oui sont assez ils
sont assez bien
nan film est pas ça insupportable c'est
insupportable images comme ça faut pas
les films et mme allard donc ce sont des
ce sont des gens que j'ai que j'ai
demandé j'ai demandé de venir ce soir
s'il te plaît s'il te fait jean-claude
c'est un pic à acheter je me cache t
olivier stirn quoi c'est oui c'est à
l'ariana 2-2 chez stirn il y en a qui va
coûter cher voilà elle voudrait des
cachets il était à quoi là et vous en
est ce que vous entendez du champagne
vous faire marrer
hama est votée et conviviaux très très
sympathique bien bonne ambiance ouatée
peut-être un 1 ou 2 1 ou 2 2 moyens goy
von der n'ont pas moyens pas bien du
tout ah bon mais ça fait partie du
public et du spectacle bah oui
souhaitent chanter bien une caméra de
filmer dans la nuit tombée de voir gros
derrière c'est un métier mais c'est très
très gentil mais bien j'en suis très
fière une bombe ont spectaculairement
tiré je conseille aux gens de le faire
si c'est toi tu as fais ce métier toi eh
bien c'était soit j'étais peintre chez
renault au céleri de céleri des 4l ils
ont arrêté la fabrication des 4l les
joueurs
maintenant s'il vous plaît bon je crois
que c'est là c'est sérieux l'on me
donner à chacun un métier et donc j'ai
dit ouais je pouvais partir au portugal
pour faire là
les sièges de 4l ouais mais j'ai une
femme et cet enfant je peux pas je peux
pas vivre au portugal je le crois pas du
tout la langue
j'ai pas là-bas pour ça non plus donc tu
as des scènes - poils sous les bras que
les ouvriers du portugal oui j'ai pas
tout compris mais voilà non mais c'est
un j'aime beaucoup le décidé de faire
rire les gens
enfin appelons ça rires oui ma foi oui
on peut appeler ça rire les gens fin les
gens si ce sont des gens je ne sais pas
ce que ce sont ceux s'éteint c'est un
public
mais quand il a été touché quand son
petit veau désamarrée les gg tout était
très petit si vous n'êtes jamais sûr
c'est aussi ces tunnels
c'est une ça commençait en 50 2 ouais
donc l'algérie n'était encore pas mal
taper si toi en ce moment je peux être
arrêté ce métier très vite d'ailleurs
non non non non non c'était la seule
façon de savoir si quelqu'un est
intéressé vous prendre quelqu'un qui est
apte à celle là mais qui continue et les
photos de métier a très peu que vous
voulez dire à l'heure actuelle
vous faites quoi vos jeux costumière
aiguillettes avant pas mal
cela n'empêche pas l'autre c'est quoi
tous et je vous le dis je n'oublie pas
le genre de mec avoir inscrit et ben si
et à bon et ça surprend à et au but donc
à garder les regarder ses joueurs à cet
âge là s'inquiète un idole mon ni mon
idole art.r dans le rire ouais je
réfléchis là j'aime c'est cette question
simple il faut répondre c'est un petit
moment sérieux j'aime beaucoup alex
métayer
ouais bah oui et puis j'aimais beaucoup
bourvil ouais surtout bon ville mais
celle l'aide des tirs et à michèle
abitbol est mort de rire
c'est la seule fois où il fait rien on
l'a coupée au montage
[Rires]
je n'ai rien à leur dire je
ils ont voté pour moi ils en subissent
les conséquences
ouais c'est courant en ce moment ça oui
oui c'est pour ça que je le dis merci et
merci de votre fidélité de votre
confiance
et puis j'espère qu'un jour je serai
haut de l'affiché
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
bonjour france et russie sinon quoi ces
russes avocat lui l'ex-roi triste
la triste musicale de ces réseaux
services là c'est patrice nostalgie
nostalgie ne s'apprend qu'à aigle et
vodka c'est tout et notre là ça prend à
la main voilà
[Musique]
et
mais
[Musique]
tranquille michmich religieux non michou
fêté son appartement
c'est complaire à déshabiller mais diaby
toile immédiatement à l'est voilà vas-y
vas-y vas-y moi j'ai pas vu le bitume en
2011 seront face brefs délais
[Musique]
comment ça marche
j'étais à trois chiffres a dit moi j'en
ai parlé film en fin de semaine qu'ils
allaient saisir
[Musique]
et
j'habite de seul avec maman
dans un très vieil appartement
bruce asa
j'ai
me tenir compagnie
bonsoir bonsoir ici bien oui on voulait
vous dire bonsoir oui pourquoi révéler
pourquoi encore pour quel plaisir pour
l'occasion de l'anniversaire de michou
pour ses 100 à 1 500 ans
j'ai aussi d'inviter basse et
s'entendent michaud soit soir
comment ça va ça va très bien richard
hasard
j'aime
me tenir compagnie
une tortue
canarie
et le chat
à tort
pour lui c'est m
très pro mais le temps de se baptiser
les pans les visages une heure à une
avocate entre s'habille se préparer on
sera prêts pons ah ouais on cale que ça
comme ça tu fais quoi toi la c2 et
jamais la cat way for ce soir tu fais
quoi
ben ouais c'est la politique mais
message de quoi la carte
[Musique]
jeane manson et le moindre accroc
et une chatte
pour le cinéma
très souvent
c'est le marché
et la cuisine
[Musique]
je range jeu là je suis à l'occasion
faisait froid jeudi à l'opéra
ah bon bien dans ses commentaires
parce que je connaissais un ami à michou
le lien lien
il est bon je veux bien essayé j'avais
déjà je savais comment il faut marquer
j'avais l'habitude de la scène de la
plus grande je suis passé à la plus
petite sur gratte
non ça fait longtemps que moi oui
printemps je termine en fin de 2e année
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le travail
je suis un peu
décorateur
ski
j'ai choisi de faire cela parce que
c'est tombé comme ça j'ai là où fou oui
oui depuis jaffe oui quelle chanson qui
prétendent cela comme je les aime toutes
pas à pas les chansons eux surtout les
gens pour deux défaites
les rois mages holnon n'ont ils vraiment
cherché non l'homme est sincère et
servent non j'aime pas d'époque spencer
c'est parce que tu es là elle a fait le
ce sont 45 tours lors ebay mais je les
fais ici ça c'était super je vais un peu
de chance car je les fait enceinte avec
le gosse sangosse je suis passé par
toutes les époques les aw est là on
avancer un peu en avance maquillage des
yeux commencent à faire le jeu délicat
mais après je fais les bouches entouré
il est rond rouge la schl pour le
preneur
qu'est ce qu'il fait dans le prologue
mais prend l'axé prenait avec nolan
c'est l'ouverture
s'écoute décembre david à cette heure la
journée oui c'est beaucoup au plus des
chansons en de belles chansons réalistes
comme mourir sur scène pour en arriver
là
on prépare le seul brave autres comme ça
et tous ces regards pas pleinement les
trucs moder enfin je crois pas que david
à des coûts tout en variétés actuelles
qu'est ce que j'aime bien c'est la dance
ah oui je trouve que ça ressemble un peu
au disco une belle musique l'aneth
on met en avant un disque mais c'est
tout aussi fini à plus de dettes mais ya
pas de carrière donc on entend ça une
fois deux fois puis après on les a mis
en vedette au suivant voilà on
représente des dernières grandes stars
qui jean ferré qui font rêver
un peu ce qui
oui
easter mais mon vrai métier c'est la
nuit
je n'exerce travay en vierge sur le nom
puisque ici on fait la crèche vivante
sous les noms je suis bien là didon
voilà ici avec mon fils joseph leroy ton
fils et oui je crie zouaoui pas de fille
sinon je voulais pas que mon corps j'ai
des fans elle n'est pas déformé encore
voilà de sirène vous savez tout sinon
pardon habitent ou paris mais à quel
endroit
20e ils étaient voisins ils savent que
tu monsieur quelques-uns quelques
commerçants depuis l'temps 1 au prisunic
en bas de chez moi
depuis le temps que j'achète des
fossiles délimité par des collants ils
disent mais qu'est ce qu'elle va voir
comment ça se passe à côté
oui alexis
je m'exerce avait ski
je suis inquiet
mister était voisin de ça tu fais ça tu
sois toi tu vois ça je me dis que je
dise du bien aux gens
ils étaient parents
ils savent oui non et alors tu vois dit
quoi xavier est un garçon qui venait
devant une fille c'est le choix de
droite mais voilà vous avez un garçon
pendant toute une époque
ils viennent des fois non ça va venir
ah oui c'est bien tombé sa crête [__]
foot je sais pas peut-être
ok ok l'un n'empêche pas l'autre
oui c'est vrai c'est beau c'est couleurs
après stripteaseur et dans la salle
debout à cannes
lehmann
valeur sûre
je suis un homme au 2010
subitement livre de t'expliquer redit
son coin quelques malades voilà à chiner
dans les quatre grands pins de castries
pour toutes à remotiver
bref on monte maintenant à les réaliser
en piste en pis pour le prologue est ce
que ça prend les barreaux
c'est quoi un parfum nous à jada on se
dépêche les filles oui on est prêtes en
deux minutes sur seuls 10 ont réservé y
est on se dépasse moi je la méchante que
ça va on se dépêche de prime abord les
biens les plus faisait assez bonne issue
c'est ce qui m'a dit michaud oui l'a dit
mais les cheveux ils vont qui m'a dit on
dirait pas des chevaux et de la barbe à
papa
ah oui c'est tout à fait mais par le
temps la peinture est parti c'est vrai
on regarde si ces blancs c'est le
frottement le frottement de chéruy quoi
eh bien je m'occupais aussi dans les
yeux pas folle la guêpe et quid des
plannings
super au coin on se dépêche
on se presse un peu
hortensia
pas celle là
quelle m
ah c'est vrai déjà des mini jeux
comprendre ma femme se méfie de toits
plats j'ai raison quand je te vois tu as
bien je comprends que ma femme se méfie
toi à ton art ancien sur des pêcheries à
oui on se dit oh là là tenue dans cette
loge non non pas toute nue heureusement
on se dépêche lingots diminue confronté
le bazar lehmann n'en croient pas leurs
yeux
je suis un hameau 2010
tu fais après alors qu'un ouragan
tu sors un peu après mais juste la wii
serait non tu vas après au banana je
pouvais tu dis ça je te connais les
trois heures du matin
on va main
[Musique]
de tous les saints
ça
dans un quelconque par là bas
on s'en donne à coeur
forcer sur le noir soit les supérieurs
non par une bouche de drag queen c'est
pas une bouse drag queens est ainsi une
mouche tandis drag queen l'europe et
c'est que maintenant il ya des drag king
oui ça c'est extraordinaire ça les
filles qui s'habillent on mac c'est ce
qu'elle n'est pas stéphane de 23 ans que
je fais ça je veux bien garçon regardait
pas comme ça messieurs et à l'intimité
c'est quand même trois ans puis jeanne
encore le caracal un bond en avant cela
on se dépêche
il suffit et affrontant texte c'est quoi
publicité qu'on peut palabres inutiles
et dis-moi tu te dépêches un peu soit
elle et ses prêches oui bon allez on y
va aller allez les filles en piste
quelconque bar tabac est là
on s'en donne à coeur joie
échanges
ce
[Musique]
moi tu t'appelles n'était pas pensable
que j'ai fait ça et dise quoi que tu
dises ça devant un fait accompli
il faut dire la vérité j'ai pas mal
accompli finalement le fait est pas mal
accompli pour dire non c'est le premier
jour très difficile pour les parents
c'est pas toujours les parents c'est
l'entourage départ oui les parents en
fait ils ont une vie acceptable
pétitionnent compassion enfants c'est le
voyez il ya tous les angles et en
schiste i maschi c'est très joli
et sans complet
on déballe nous rajouter savate et
maquis qu'est ce qui doit être content
michou d'avoir quelqu'un qu'elle veut
plus comme lui le bleu michou je sens il
a un peu dictateur on empêche de prendre
la balle entre les choux un peu
d'histoire non non
non ce cas cela organiser pas de
planning onu
attention mesdames messieurs dans un
instant ça va commencer
mais jean le fait avec humour
robin en décalant nous
il est
la cie
on
[Musique]
qui pour épater leurs tables et
pourriture celui de ses deux chats c4
commencé la musique de 4,6
longtemps la fortune
vitesse ou année
et puis tout mon potentiel je ne fais
pas dire dans ces seuls à vraiment aller
au salon un mot ici
oh oh là là ne coince à new york où
thierry cessa de jeu aussi non donc il
marche ca s'est sagement jacques à
suleija je manger une choucroute
conseiller ça s'adresse partir alors en
avant la seconde
[Musique]
m
avec
moore avec
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
eschau
[Musique]
cher
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai joué
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
new morning sait où
en descendant en droite soirée
je
[Musique]
e
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais
quand tu démarres capable d'envoyer ton
corps à la grande aventure
les lumières les plombs qu'on s'était tu
croyais pas de la littérature
une semaine durant pour les boules parce
que là le voir lui que tout grand père
grand benêt femme et sa petite fille
perdue dans la campagne pathétique itélé
soccer page one est immuable
[Musique]
et
l'accès
son temps
au contraire
moi
ça on
ça
à
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
2 il a l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez
un peu de bleu